Nancy Pelosi can't contain her glee as
she conveys impeachment to the Senate
the Government Accountability Office
dumps all over Trump and we finally know
what Warren and Sanders said to each
other I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro show is
sponsored by expressvpn stand up for
your digital rights visit expressvpn
comm slash man well it's almost as
though there is some sort of
coordination going on as the impeachment
charges are conveyed to the Senate why
in the last 24 hours
it's as though a bevy of bombshells have
dropped on President Trump in the midst
of this impeachment inquiry they didn't
drop for weeks for months actually while
the Democrats were pursuing their
impeachment investigation Democrats
didn't bother calling any of the
relevant witnesses but now we have two
big bombshell stories dropping within
literally hours of each other and all of
that within hours of Nancy Pelosi
conveying the impeachment charges to the
Senate I mean maybe all of that's a
coincidence or maybe it's not so
coincidental in any case we're gonna go
through all of it momentarily but the
big news yesterday was that Nancy Pelosi
had finally decided to stop holding up
impeachment she was going to convey the
impeachment charges to the Senate and
she was gleeful in doing so we were told
this was sober remember was sober
serious it was really imperative that
everybody took this whole thing with the
with the amount of dignity that it
required well I don't think the Nancy
Pelosi was too sober and too serious
yesterday aside from handing out golden
pens after she signed the impeachment
which again there's some precedent for
it but not a great look Nancy Pelosi
basically could not contain herself as
all of this happen she signed the
articles and she handed them over and
you can watch how it looked again didn't
look very sober and serious to me but
that is the way that it is you can't
contain her smile she's so happy
she literally cannot stop smiling as
this is happening but don't worry it's
incredibly sober at sanity it's
incredibly serious and she's writing
each letter of her name with the
different pens that she can hand out the
pens to all of those who have worked so
hard to impeach President Trump and here
she is conveying the impeachment charges
to somebody and everybody is clearly
pretty happy about this Maxine Waters
standing right behind Pelosi and also
unable to contain herself Nancy Pelosi
then came out and talked about how sad
she is about all this again not able to
contain her joy so sad so tragic for a
country that the actions taken by the
President to undermine our national
security to violate his oath of office
and to jeopardize the security of our
elections the integrity of our elections
has taken us to this place
big old grins
guys it's so sober it's so serious we
have to we if we don't take this
seriously it's because it's our fault
it's not because it this whole thing by
Nancy Pelosi was basically a blown
political opportunity for her no it's
it's not that this is political in any
way it's that we didn't take it
seriously
so Pelosi was I mean she was giddy she
was handing out the Pens and she was
giddy handing out the Pens you can see
she is just extraordinarily happy
everybody smiling holding up their pens
oh my gosh
it's like they just won an Oscar I mean
really really exciting stuff and then
she of course announced that impeachment
was forever impeachment and because
impeachment is forever her work here is
done so this is the neener neener neener
impeachment here's Nancy Pelosi
yesterday suggesting that Trump's
impeachment will last forever no matter
what happens going forward in the Senate
the president is not above the law he
will be held accountable he has been
held accountable he has been impeached
he's been impeached forever they can
never erase that well it's over it's
over
so I mean now that he's been impeached I
guess we can all go home happy right I
mean she's happy can we're gonna get to
the actual bombshells that have been
dropping left and right in just one
second first let us talk about what you
do if you have an employee who just
isn't really cutting it let's say that
you have an employee let's come
Chadd and let's say that chad is a
really swell dude I mean somebody just
great makes sure that your family is
safe and protect let's say that chad has
a side career that interests him more
than his central career let's say that
he's very into moviemaking and has
appeared and actually a Best Picture
flick this year well let's say that Chad
really he's got a future in a different
industry but you just want to help him
accelerate that future in a different
industry by looking for a replacement
for somebody like Chad well you would be
looking to zip recruiter com zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technologies zip recruiter
scans thousands of resumes to find
people with the right experience and
then invites them to apply to your job
as applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes each one and spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match zipper career is so effective that
four out of five employers who post on
zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the very first
day it's important to get hiring right
because you don't want to have to sit on
your employees to focus on their job
Chad instead what you want is an
employee who's focused like a laser
people on their job this is where a zip
recruiter comes in right now Matt
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that's
right
zip recruiter comm slash Dai ly WI re
zip recruiter comm slash daily white
reciprocally is indeed the smartest way
to hire ok so the Democrats better have
some bombshells in waiting here because
what they conveyed to the Senate doesn't
have bombshells what they conveyed to
the Senate doesn't even have an
articulated Crime Chris Wallace over at
Fox News who has been no proponents of
the president throughout this process he
says look Nancy Pelosi blew this she
could not make Mitch McConnell bow to
her will I want to just talk if I could
briefly Harris about the speaker
Pelosi's delay the month delay in
sending over the articles of impeachment
because I think you can see it two ways
if if the purpose was to force Mitch
McConnell to to bow to her will and to
agree to call witnesses and to get more
documents than it was a total failure
there's no question about it ok so that
is true well Nancy Pelosi has picked her
team and she's picked an extraordinarily
political team she didn't attempt to
drive any sort of bipartisan consensus
by picking well-respected members of her
House contingent instead she decided
that she was going to bring forth the
most radical members of her contingent
she said that she is going to
deploy Adam Schiff she's also going to
play Jerry Nadler of the Judiciary
Committee - a Pelosi quote unquote top
lieutenants according to the Associated
Press Nadler says president from gravely
abused the power of his office he did
all of this for his personal political
gain ahead of Wednesday's session Schiff
released new records from Lev Parnas an
associate of Trump Larry Rudy Giuliani
about the Ukraine strategy including an
exchange with another man about
surveilling later fired ambassador
Murray Ivanovich Schiff said that the
new evidence should bring more pressure
on McConnell to call Lev partners as
witness there is there are a couple
questions about that one lift harness is
under indictment - Lev Parnas could have
been called by the house and the house
didn't bother to call him but according
to Adam Schiff you know there's new
evidence likely to emerge and behold
within 24 hours new evidence is emerging
almost as though something was mildly
coordinated here here's Adam chef
there's a tremendous volume of documents
and materials that mr. Parnas has turned
over to us we are still going through
them wolf because there's such a great
volume many of them are in a Russian and
they had to be translated unfortunately
we have members of our staff that can
help do that but there is still a great
many other documents to go through and
it's not just what we got from Lev
Parnas and then Adam Schiff then talks
about how there will be more live
partners documents that are forthcoming
in the very near future ESA's we're
still going through the partners
document so shift obviously is is
treating the house impeachment effort as
though it is not over which is weird
since they just conveyed the impeachment
charges to the Senate okay this brings
us to today's bombshell so we have a
couple of bombshells that we have to go
through today and let's be frank about
this none of this is fantastic for
President Trump
I mean presidents from wasn't his
behavior with regard to Ukraine was bad
okay the reason that it was bad was not
because he was interested in buries MA
or hunter Biden or Joe Biden or any of
the rest of it the reason that it was
bad is because he has law enforcement
agencies at his disposal and deploying
Rudy Giuliani who has a tenuous grasp on
reality to say the least to Ukraine or
dig up dirt that would prove that 2016
it was Ukrainian election hacking that
was responsible rather than Russian
election hacking president Trump's
tendency to buy into his own conspiracy
theories with regard to CrowdStrike
hiding Hillary Clinton's server in
Ukraine all of that was sure nonsense
and to hold up
in military aid in order to go after all
that information was bad policy and was
bad policy from the start now you can
make the argument that President Trump
was doing that not with an eye toward
2020 now with an eye toward corrupting
the 2020 presidential race it was with
an eye toward 2016 and uncovering what
he thought to be corruption and so is
his version his ill-founded version of
the moto report that basically the
Mullah report was all about Russian
interference in 2016 in Trump's response
was 2016 was not about Russia it was
about Ukraine and I'm deploying my
friend Rudy Giuliani and his friends so
go and investigate this whole thing
inside Ukraine and that is going to ask
questions about Ukrainian corruption and
Ukrainian coordination with the Obama
administration and all the rest of this
and I've been suggesting for a while
that I think that that situation is much
more plausible than he did it in order
to quote-unquote get Joe Biden in 2020
and notice how the charges here have
morphed right the charges here have
morphed from President Trump was going
after Joe Biden to have the Ukrainian
government basically manipulate
information to take Biden out of the
2020 race or hurt Joe Biden and then
they moved to president Trump doesn't
have the authority to do any of these
things that he actually has the
authority to do like fire ambassador
Murray Ivanovitch well this brings us to
the big bombshell story of the day we'll
get to the left part and stuff in just a
second which is a little more
complicated this brings us to the big
bombshell story of the day that big
bombshell story of the day is that the
Government Accountability Office has now
released an eight-page letter suggesting
that the Trump administration violated
what is called the impoundment Control
Act which was passed in 1974 when the
administration did not convey to
Congress the reason for holding up
Ukrainian military aid and there had
been some signals that this was going to
become an issue for the Trump
administration as soon as it was
announced that Trump had held up the
aide without really giving me an excuse
to Congress now the impoundment Control
Act made kind of an obscure provision of
federal law it was passed in 1974 in
response to a Supreme Court decision
declaring that President Nixon could not
simply withhold budget requirements that
had been passed by Congress so Congress
had passed certain budgetary items sent
them over to the President of the United
States the President of the United
States Nixon had refused to then spend
the money and Congress soon went to the
Supreme Court the Supreme Court said no
Nixon does have to spend the money that
has been allocated to the executive
branch the executive branch does not in
fact have a quote unquote line-item veto
right which is which allow the executive
to basically cut down on spending by
refusing to spend money already
allocated by the legislative branch the
legislative branch has the power of the
purse the executive branch doesn't get
to pick and choose which parts of the
allocations it wants to spend and the
impoundment Control Act which may or may
not be constitutional that was passed in
the direct aftermath of that Supreme
Court case now this has always been a
sort of controversial provision of
federal law daniel henan sure writing
back in 2011 over at The Wall Street
Journal he points out here is a list of
US presidents and public figures who
have used or supported the impoundment
power impoundment power would be
Congress allocates money for something
the president says nope not spending it
here is a list of people who have
supported the impoundment power Abe
Lincoln Franklin Roosevelt Harry Truman
JFK LBJ Bill Clinton the bushes John
McCain John Kerry Al Gore Pat Buchanan
jeb Hensarling russ feingold joe
lieberman Judd Gregg Paul Ryan and
Barack Obama Daniel Hannan sure rights
in the early 1970s Richard Nixon tried
aggressively to impound spending
touching off a war with Congress's
prerogatives then watergate broke in a
fury one of the most liberal congress
has passed the Budget Control Act of
1974 it transferred most spending
control to Congress which one
commentator at the time called
congressional government and chaos and
it's unclear exactly how did if I
divided this Authority and the Supreme
Court and coin-flip decisions has tended
to side with Congress many sort of
political watchers over the past few
years have suggested including Barack
Obama that having the president have a
sort of line-item veto power to be able
to not spend that sort of money would be
a good thing but suffice to say the
impoundment Control Act is an operative
act of law right that is something that
is so with that said there are specific
provisions to the impoundment Control
Act the impoundment Control Act dictates
the president has to spend money that is
allocated to the executive branch within
a certain period of time if it is not
allocated within a certain period of
time then it will then the executive
branch has to make a report to the
legislative branch and if the
legislative branch does not make a
report the executive branch does not
make a report to the legislative branch
and this is the key then the legislative
branch is supposed to launch its own
inquiry into why the executive branch is
not doing that and or file lawsuits so
there is no impeachable offense in
violating the impoundment Control Act in
the sense that there is an actual
statutory remedy for this right in the
statute it says what is supposed to
happen if the president doesn't violate
the Budget Control Act if he violates
the impoundment Act and the answer is
not impeachment the answer right there
is that the Comptroller General is
supposed to file a lawsuit a civil
lawsuit against the President of the
United States against the executive
branch which did not happen here at no
point does the Comptroller General of
the United States who by the way is a
Barack Obama appointee with a 15 year
term and no point was that lawsuit
actually filed okay so this is more a
matter of sort of imagery and imagistic
s-- then it is a matter of okay now he's
committed an impeachable offense through
the impoundment Act in fact there been
allegations that Trump was violating the
impoundment Control Act with regard to
Puerto Rico because he wasn't freeing up
the money to go to Puerto Rico fast
enough this is a pretty regular feature
of American government that the
executive branch is accused of not doing
Congress's will and spending money that
has already been allocated by Congress
okay so now the only the office of
management of budget said no we didn't
violate the impoundment Act and you have
the General Accounting Office the the
government accountability office rather
suggesting that the Act has indeed been
violated so here is what the GAO found
today they say in the summer of 2019 OMB
withheld from obligation approximately
two hundred fourteen million dollars
appropriated to the Department of
Defense for security assistance to
Ukraine as explained below we conclude
that OMB withheld the funds from
obligation for an unauthorized reason in
violation of the impoundment Control Act
we also questioned actions regarding
funds appropriated to the Department of
State for security assistance to Ukraine
in accordance with our regular practice
we contacted OMB the Executive Office of
the President and Zod to seek factual
information and their legal views on the
matter
OMB provided a written response letter
and certain apportionment schedules for
security assistance funding for Ukraine
the executive office of the president
responded to our request by referring to
the letter we had received from OMB and
providing that the White House did not
plan to send a separate response thus
far the DoD has not provided a response
or a timeline for when we will receive
one on October 30th 2019 Senator Chris
Van Hollen Democrat of Delaware asked
the Controller General about this matter
during a hearing before the Senate
Committee on the budget and then they
get into the background we'll get into
that in just one second first let's talk
about a brand-new way the bad people
have of stealing your money and then
people online criminals are incredibly
clever they've found ways to steal
credit card numbers they've done ways to
steal your data well here's a brand-new
but they're going about stealing your
data and they could actually bankrupt
you this is called home title theft I
mean what they are doing right now is
they they actually go online they find
your home title they find the documents
that you filed for your home title and
then they hijack those documents they
alter the documents and then they run up
tabs on the basis of your home equity no
this is a thing that is happening Debra
says criminal found the title to our
home online and filed forged documents
claiming they owned it she says I was
evicted from my own home and 85 grand
inequities stolen nobody believes you
can get your home stolen this easily but
as all of these records becoming
digitized as it's easier and easier for
hackers to access that data and then to
go after your home title and then you
use that I mean it's it's probably the
biggest asset you own in all likelihood
and then use that to rack up all sorts
of charges to take out loans to steal
your home title this is dangerous stuff
well good news there's a way for you to
protect against all of this go to home
title lock calm right now that's home
title lock and calm right now
register your address to see if your
home's title has been tampered with if
so you should call police if not you
should register your home for 60
risk-free days of protection at home
title lock calming and that's home a
title lock time when money can solve
your peace of mind problems you should
totally do it home title lock calm this
is a thing that is Forbes report on it's
the thing that's increasingly been
happening and again as criminals realize
that this is an actual way of gaining
money they're gonna be increasingly
doing a protect your home title today at
home title lock calm again at home title
lock calm okay back to this Government
Accountability Office report suggesting
that the president violated the
impoundment Control Act for foes for
fiscal year 2019 Congress appropriated
250 million dollars for the Ukraine
security assistance initiative the funds
were available to provide assistance
including training equipment lethal
assistance logistics support supplies
and services sustainment and
intelligence support to the military and
national security forces of Ukraine Zod
was required to notify Congress 15 days
in advance of any obligation of the USA
I funds in order to obligate more than
50 percent of the amount appropriated
GOG was also required to certify to
Congress that Ukraine had taken
substantial actions on defense
institutional reforms in its
certification GOG did include
descriptions of its planned expenditures
totaling 125 million dollars on July
25th 2015
OMB issued the first
9 apportionment schedules with footnotes
regarding USA I funds withholding with
USA i funds from obligation the footnote
said amounts reapportioned but not yet
obligated as of the date of this
reapportionment for the Ukraine Security
Assistance initiative are not available
for obligation until August 5th 2019 to
allow for an interagency process to
determine the best use of such funds
based on OMB communication with DoD OMB
understands from the department that
this brief pause and obligations will
not preclude DoD's timely execution of
the final policy direction DoD may make
continued its planning in case work for
the initiative during this period on
both August 6th and 15 2019 OMB approved
additional apportionment actions to
extend this pause and obligations with
footnotes that except for the dates were
identical to the July 25th 2019
apportionment actions they kept
basically saying that we are
investigating we're trying to figure out
the best way to spend the money
OMB approved additional apportionment
actions on August 20th 27th and 31st and
on September 5th 6th and 10th the
footnotes from these additional
apportionment actions were except for
the days otherwise identical to one
another and nevertheless differed from
those of July 25th and August 6 and 15
2019 and that they omitted the second
sentence that appeared in the earlier
portion in actions regarding OMB so
understanding that the pause and
obligation would not preclude timely
obligation so now they're saying well
maybe it will preclude timely obligation
okay well as we'll see under the Act
it's the timely obligation aspect of
here that makes the situation ripe for
violation of the impoundment Control Act
because there is in fact a statutory
period where they can consider whether
to release the funds if you don't
release the funds in time then you're
supposed to send a notice to Congress
the apportionment schedules issued on
August 27th and 31st 2019 and on
September 5th 6/10 2019 works identical
except for the dates according to OMB
approximately 214 million dollars of the
US AI appropriation was withheld as a
result of these footnotes OMB did not
transmit a special message proposing to
defer or rescind the funds so the
question is whether OMB had the
authority to withhold or defer the funds
according to the GAO the Constitution
specifically vest Congress with the
power of the purse providing that quote
no money shall be drawn from the
Treasury but in consequence of the
appropriations made by law the
Constitution also vests all legislative
powers in Congress and sets forth the
procedures of bicameralism and
presentiments now they're going through
the law suggesting
that the president has to faithfully
execute the law by spending the money
allocated to him by Congress in
Appropriations Act is a wall like any
other therefore unless Congress has
enacted a law providing otherwise the
president must take care to ensure that
appropriations are prudently obligated
during their period of availability the
constant the Constitution grants the
president no unilateral authority to
withhold funds from obligation instead
Congress has vested the president was
strictly circumscribed authority to
impound or withhold budget Authority
only in limited circumstances expressly
provided in the impoundment Control Act
and here's where they get into the
actual law that they say Trump violated
the ICA separates impoundment into two
exclusive categories deferrals and
rescissions the President may
temporarily withhold funds from
obligation but not beyond the end of the
fiscal year in which the president
transmits the special message by
proposing a deferral okay so this is
important the president did not actually
propose a recession a rescission rate he
didn't rescind the funds he deferred the
funds he actually signed over the funds
in September after the whistleblower
story was filed at that point you're
still in the same fiscal year so this
does not count as a rescission it counts
as a deferral the President may also
seek the permanent cancelation of funds
for fiscal policy or other reasons
including the termination of programs
for which Congress has provided budget
Authority by proposing a rescission
which he didn't write the in either case
the ICA requires that the president
transmit a special message to Congress
that includes the amount of budget
Authority proposed for deferral or
session and the reason for the proposal
these special messages must provide
detailed and specific reasoning to
justify the withholding as set out in
the ICA so Democrats are going to claim
and it's a cover-up because president
from did not actually convey a special
message to Congress suggesting why the
funds were being withheld
there's no assertion or other indication
here that OMB intended to propose such a
rescission not only did OMB not submit a
special message with such a proposal the
footnotes and the apportionment
schedules by their very terms
established dates for the release of the
amounts withheld the only other
Authority then would have been a
deferral the ICA authorizes the deferral
of budget Authority in a limited range
of circumstances to provide for
contingencies to achieve savings made
possible or through changes in
requirements or greater efficiency of
operations or a specifically provided by
law no officer or employee of the US may
defer budget Authority for any other
purpose here OMB did not identify any
contingencies as recognized by the ICA
savings or efficiencies that would
result from withholding or any law
specifically authorizing the withholding
instead the foot
in the important schedules described
withholding as necessary quote to
determine the best use of such funds and
its response to us and be described the
withholding is necessary to ensure that
the funds were to quote not spent in a
manner that could conflict with the
president's foreign policy the ICA does
not permit deferrals for policy reasons
om B's justification for withholding
falls squarely within the scope of an
impermissible policy deferral thus the
deferral of us AI funds was improper
under the ICA okay all of that is
perfectly fair by the way right when the
GAO says that the President of the
United States does not have the power to
simply for policy reasons withhold the
funding under the ICA that's correct
that's correct so the question becomes
what is then the solution for when the
president does not comply with his
obligation here really this is just a
fight between the branches it's a normal
fight between the legislative branch and
the executive branch
now the GAO says faithful execution of
the law does not permit the President to
substitute his own policy priorities for
those that Congress has enacted into law
in fact Congress was concerned about
exactly these types of withholdings when
it enacted and later amended the ICA but
Trump released the funding so the big
complaint here is that Trump did not
inform Congress as to why he was
withholding the funding he didn't make
it public and then when he was called on
it he released the funding well that's
not a good look I've been saying that
since the very beginning it may be a
violation of the impoundment Control Act
frankly there's only one problem
has a very specific solution in the
impoundment Control Act and it is not
impeachment I'll get to that in just one
second so the GAO concludes om B's
assertions have no basis in law because
it only be asserts that it's actions are
not subject to the ICA because they
constitute a programmatic delay it
argues that a policy development process
is a fundamental part of program
implementation
so it's empowerment of funds for the
sake of a policy process is programmatic
OMB further argues that because reviews
for compliance with statutory conditions
and congressional mandates are
considered pragmatic so too should be
reviews undertaken to ensure compliance
with presidential policy prerogatives om
B's assertions say the GOI the GAO
rather have no basis in law we recognize
that even where the president does not
transmit a special message pursuant to
the procedures established by the ICA it
is possible that a delay an obligation
may not constitute a reportable
impoundment however programmatic delays
occur when an agency is taking necessary
steps to implement a program but because
of factors external to the program funds
temporary temporarily go unobligated
this presumes of course the agency is
making reasonable efforts to obligate so
now they're making the argument that
it's true Trump didn't withhold the
funds right the funds went forward but
the reason that he didn't withhold the
funds was not sufficiently given to
Congress and not only that you can't
call it a programmatic delay because a
programmatic delay is we meant to give
the funding and then exigent
circumstances barred us from giving the
funding the GAO says at the time OMB
issued the first apportionment footnote
withholding the u.s. AI funds DoD had
already produced a plan for expending
the funds DoD had decided on the items
of plan to purchase and have provided
this information to Congress on May 23rd
2019 therefore programmatic spending was
already underway so we can't accept
allenbys assertion that its actions are
programmatic we conclude that OMB
violated the ica when it's when it
withheld u.s. AI funds for policy
reasons
hey now there are a couple of problems
with this with this whole thing
okay so Josh Josh Blackman is a law
professor over at the cato institute and
he has a threat on this is the GA found
GAO found that OMB violated the
impoundment act and suggested that the
president president violated his duty to
take care and the laws are faithfully
executed to breat to be precise
president did not and could not
personally violate the impoundment act
because the law does not control his
personal actions his liability if it
exists at all derives from his failure
to supervise that his subordinates
faithfully executed the law Seth Tillman
and I explained this dichotomy in the
impeachment context Trump's liability
could result from knowing from knowingly
failing to take care that his
subordinates faithfully executed the law
most of the criticisms we received
assume that president personally
violated the ICA OMB violated the
statute not the president whether the
president violated his duty of faithful
execution is a different question that
the OMB does not decide but only hints
at beyond that even a violation of law
even a violation of law in this
particular case does not necessarily
mean that the proper solution is
impeachment the reason I say that the
reason I say that is because the law
itself the law itself has in answer to
this u.s. code to section 687 chapter 2
section 687
suits by Comptroller General if under
this chapter budget Authority is
required to be made available for
obligation and such but budget Authority
is not made available for obligation the
Comptroller General is hereby expressly
empowered through attorneys of his own
selection to bring a civil action in the
United States District Court for the
District of Columbia to require such
budget authority to be made available
for obligation in such Court is hereby
expressly empowered to enter in so in
such civil action against any department
agency officer or employee of the United
States and need to create judgment or
order which may be necessary or
appropriate to make such budget
authority available for obligation no
civil action shall be brought by the
Comptroller General under the section
until the expiration of 25 calendar days
of continuous session of Congress
following the date on which an
explanatory statement by the Comptroller
General of the circumstances giving rise
to the action contemplated has been
filed with the Speaker of the House of
Representatives and the president of the
Senate in other words the Comptroller
General is supposed to file a lawsuit
against the president in the DC Circuit
Court of Appeals it's not supposed to be
impeachable now again this has been
considered for quite a while as a
possibility that the there was going to
be an attempt to use the ICA to smack
trump nathanael Cogley road piece over
at the Washington Examiner Cogley is an
assistant professor of poli-sci at
Tarleton State University in Texas and
he went through all of this he points
out a few things he says Democrats have
long sought whatever excuse was
available to impeach but the law
prescribes a much less drastic remedy
for when a president withhold
appropriated funds first the committee's
report falsely characterizes what the
law says about the temporary withholding
or deferral of funds the the the
original report by the impeachment
committee the Intelligence Committee
says quote any amounts of budgetary
Authority proposed to be deferred or
rescinded must be made available for
obligation unless Congress completes
action on a bill rescinding all or part
of the amount proposed for rescission
but this is false
although permanently rescinded funds
might must be made available in this
manner the language in Section 684
contains no such requirement for funds
that are temporarily withheld or
deferred as in the case of the aid to
Ukraine the difference between
rescission and an impoundment resolution
is actually pretty significant here the
former must be taken up by Congress
before the end of the first period of 45
calendar days but the latter an
impoundment resolution has no timeline
also the report implies that Trump
failed to send a special message and
that is an obstructive act but if you
read the law it's not because
the Comptroller General finds that the
president has failed to transmit a
special message with respect to such
Reserve or deferral the Comptroller
General makes a report and such report
shall be considered a special message
transmitted under Section 683 or 684 in
other words if the president does not
transmit a special message explaining
why the thing has been deferred the
Comptroller General is supposed to make
a report and that is considered the
presidential message
so the actual remedy for all of this is
not impeachment the actual remedies that
now does that mean that Trump did the
right thing here no does this mean that
the President did suspicious stuff
absolutely but does that mean that it's
impeachable under the terms of the
impoundment Control Act it's not
impeachable like at all right it's not I
mean there's an actual solution under
the impoundment Control Act and again as
I will remind everyone the impoundment
the power of impoundment has been a
controversial power that pretty much
every president has wanted including
Barack Obama and Bill Clinton so this is
more of a fight between the executive
and legislative the legislative branch
as far as what sort of powers the
executive branch should have then
President Trump did something that is
impeachable even by the the the actual
solution of the ICA it's not impeachment
okay in just a second we're gonna get to
the other big bombshell of the day and
this of course is the testimony of Lev
Parnas who's not actually testified but
he was on Rachel Maddow last night and
everybody's going crazy about it so
we're gonna talk about what exactly love
partners had to say is he trustworthy is
he a source you should take seriously or
is he sort of like a Michael Cohen
character and you kind of take seriously
what he's saying maybe it's true but
there are a bunch of missing connected
dots here we'll get into that in just
one second first if you're not already a
daily Y remember you're truly missing
out right now using promo code Shapiro
you'll get 10% off any plan that you
choose head over to tail e wire comm /
subscribe picked the plan that is right
for you for as little as ten bucks a
month members get our articles add free
access to all of our live broadcasts and
show library the full three hours of the
Ben Shapiro show select bonus content
access to the mailbag and more plus our
new all access to your gets you into
exclusive live online Q&A discussions
with me Andrew Klavan Matt Walsh Michael
moles plus daily wire writers and
special guests and don't forget you also
get the greatest of all beverage vessels
the leftist ears tumblr yes you get all
of that plus 10% off when you use promo
code Shapiro so stop depriving yourself
come and join the fun we're the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
now quick final note on that GAO report
there are some people who are going to
point out today
commanding fairly that joe biden did in
fact threaten ukrainian aid and so did
senators right but but senators can
they're in the legislative branch which
i Buyten is not he's in the executive
branch when he was vice president he
bragged about threatening ukraine's aid
now presumably he could do that if he
went to congress and then demanded some
sort of rescission he went to congress
and he and he notified them of his
authority but let's say the joe biden
had not done that let's say that he just
threatened ukraine and said listen
they're corrupt I'm withholding this I
forgot to send the statement I didn't
feel like sending the statement would
that have been impeach abou apparently
according to the Democrats the answer is
yes I think that that is a stretch
considering the terms of the impoundment
Control Act itself okay now on to the
left par ness of it also Webb partes is
an associate of Rudy Giuliani it was
idiotic
full-stop idiotic for president Trump to
employ Rudy Giuliani as his man in
Ukraine it was fully moronic okay I've
been saying this since the very
beginning the president has an
unfortunate tendency to to believe
things that confirm his priors
he never has wanted to believe that the
Russians were involved in the 2016
election now I agree with the president
that the Russians were not the reason
the Hillary Clinton lost Hillary Clinton
is the reason that Hillary Clinton lost
but Trump's obsession with this idea
that it wasn't the Russians it was
actually the Ukrainians because this
apparently gets him off the hook in some
way although I'm not sure what hook he
thinks he has to get off of his belief
that it was the Ukrainians Quarter the
real problem led him to employ Rudy
Giuliani as his man in Ukraine and Rudy
Giuliani then relied on a bunch of
nefarious characters including eleven
Parnas who were people doing business in
Ukraine who had a series of
cross-cutting interests left harness was
this guy doing business in Ukraine a
bunch of Ukrainian oligarchs who didn't
like the Ambassador Murray Ivanovich
partners had been seeking ivanovich's a
sir since 2018
Jovanovic had apparently been blocking
things that Parnas wanted so partners
had his own sort of agenda in Ukraine
and then when we started talking to him
suddenly Parnas being a somewhat canny
political operator he then starts
feeding Giuliani what he thinks he wants
which is you know what happened here
Jovanovic is blocking investigations
into Biden and Ukrainian involvement in
the 2016 election you know what you
should do you should talk to Victor
shokan and all these old prosecutors who
are looking into burries mind by
becomes the funnel of information to
Giuliani who's funneling that
information to Trump
so the accusation today by members of
the left's that Lev partes was getting
orders from Trump that he was getting
orders from Trump to do illegal things
like presumably Shadow Murray Ivanovich
the Ukrainian government has now opened
an investigation into people shadowing
murray ivanovitch and partners is trying
to blame this on trump harness is going
out on national TV and he's saying it
wasn't me I wasn't initiating any of
this it was just president from
President Trump who wanted things and I
did it I was just a loyal American I was
just a lackey of the president that does
not honestly it doesn't hold true to the
record of the fact that Lev Parnas is
under indictment sitting under
indictment right now so here's 11
partners suggesting that the president
is responsible for everything he did
shifting responsibility from himself to
president Trump even though by the way
again harness has never had a
conversation with President Trump about
any of this so far as we are aware like
at all he was talking to Rudy so the
best we have is partners talking about
what he talked about with Rudy Rudy has
never been called before a committee
he was not called infront of the house
so we don't know what Rudy was being
told by Trump so again we sort of have
the Gordon Sunland problem from early on
in the impeachment process he had the EU
ambassador saying here's what I was
telling people I only talked to Trump
like once and you know it was kind of
unclear what he wanted and all of this
well let partes is again two steps
removed from Trump himself here and yet
he is testifying as to president Trump's
intentions and of course shifting
responsibility from himself and again
he'd been engaged in nefarious actions
in Ukraine for quite a while including
going after Jovanovic before Trump was
even concerned about from knew who you
was frankly he's now trying to shift
responsibility and Rachel Maddow is
therefore a banshee is there for it what
do you think is the main inaccuracy or
the main lie that's being told that you
feel like you can correct that the
president didn't know what was going on
president Trump know exactly what was
going on he was aware of all my
movements he I wouldn't do anything
without their consent the Rudy Giuliani
or the president ok so again he's trying
to shift all responsibility under
Giuliani and the president as opposed to
what appears to be more accurate which
is that Parnas was doing his own stuff
in Ukraine and then he was using
Giuliani in order to try and give him
authority and color of authority to do
things my parents wanted me with people
in Ukraine how do you do that if nobody
wants to meet with you well you find the
president's man you get the president's
man's request that you meet with those
people in Ukraine and suddenly you have
an awful lot more power I know people
who are like this in politics there are
many of them so Parnas then starts
testifying as to his impression of the
Ukrainian aid issue and again you got to
take everything in the partner says with
a with a grain of salt
even the notes that he submitted where
he says get Biden to commit get Ukraine
to --n commit zalanski to commit to
announcing an investigation of Biden is
that what Trump told him is that what
you Leone told him was that Parnas his
impression of that's all that it would
take in order to satisfy Trump right we
don't know the answer to this because
again we still have not heard testimony
from anyone except for Gordon someone
who had a direct conversation with Trump
so once again we are getting third hand
reporting by a guy with absolutely
obvious conflicting interests in let
Parnas mayor Julianne cruelly told me
after you know meeting at the president
the White House he called me a message
was it wasn't just military raid it was
all eight basically the relationships
would be sour that you would that we
would stop giving him any kind of aid
that less that there was an announcement
it was several things there wasn't the
several demands at that point a the most
important one was the announcement of
the Biden investigation me so again he's
got an agenda here and we're gonna have
to take all of this was burning assault
and and the biggest grain of salt of all
is the house never called this guy man
who's fully available to be called he
obviously wants to spill he has nothing
to hide at this point he's been
conveying documents to the House
Democrats why didn't they call him
that's a real question that the Senate
is gonna have to take up meanwhile FBI
investigators have now gone to the home
and business of a man named Robert Hyde
the agents were seen by CNN and
confirmed by a law enforcement official
who exactly is Robert Hyde
well Robert Hyde is a human who
apparently was coordinating
with other members of sort of team
Giuliani Hyde had a relationship with
leva Parnas that involves sending a
large volume of whatsapp messages and
their accusations that heíd was stalking
Marie Ivanovich the he was stalking her
around Ukraine hide called for release
of all of left Parnassus texts and he
said that the left would be offended by
what had not been made public and it was
pretty wild so Robert Hyde appeared
again there's pictures of him with with
Roger stones he's part of this whole
kind of team of dholtze he appeared on
Eric Bolling show to talk about whether
he was in fact stalking marie ivanovitch
did you when did you have eyes I come on
each other that's why we were using
whatsapp I mean I'd like to see the full
text come out because there was some
real colourful stuffs up by partners
okay so here is the latest according to
NPR Ukraine's National Police are now
investigating whether US Ambassador
Marie Ivanovich was under surveillance
in Kiev last spring something implied in
a series of whatsapp messages between
Robert Hyde and an associate of Rudy
Giuliani president Trump's personal
lawyer between Lev Parnas and Robert
hide the text made public between
partisan hide a trump supporter and
retired marine running for Congress in
Connecticut suggested the amount which
was being monitored both electronic
electronically and in person in an
apparent breach of diplomatic security
hydroton one message they're moving her
tomorrow he added the guys over there
asked me what I would like to do and
what's in it for them Ukrainian already
said the implication that an ambassador
was under illegal surveillance and her
electronic gadgets were interfered with
by the private persons at the request of
US citizens suggests a possible
violation of its own laws as well as the
Vienna Convention on diplomatic
relations which protects diplomats on
foreign soil so in other words Lev
Parnas the guy who's testifying that
this is all Trump's fault was
coordinating with Robert Hyde possibly
according to these text messages they
seem to suggest in order to surveil
Marie ivanovitch and according to
partners all this is coming top down
from from
which is weird cuz from could have just
fired you Voinovich anytime he wanted
she was his ambassador he's the
president of the United States why in
the world would he need surveillance why
would he need eyes on Marie Ivanovitch
in order to do all of us
like there's no actual reason now it's
possible that idiocy explains all of
this and the Trump is involved deeply in
the idiocy but we're gonna need to talk
to somebody who actually talked to Trump
and that is why in the end all that's
gonna happen here as the Senate is gonna
have to call some of these people as
witnesses right that's where this is
going
the Senate will in fact call these
people as witnesses there are there is
not enough support in the Senate to just
dismiss the charges outright especially
not with all of this roiling so this
impeachment thing in the Senate could
actually get fairly interesting between
talk about the impoundment Control Act
and Lev Parnas and all the rest but
suffice it to say that the media's
newfound obsession with web Parnas hero
of the resistance and they should weigh
a little bit and Michael Cohen was a was
a convicted liar web partners is under
indictment right now for corruption
those are not your best sources when it
comes to an unbiased view of what
exactly is going on here especially when
they're appearing on Rachel Maddow and
and enthusiastically feeding or whatever
it is that she wants to hear so that is
your latest on the bombshells in
impeachment gauge 2020 which is in fact
eating up right I mean both of those are
relevant pieces of information left on a
story and the GAO story again the GAO
story I tend to actually kind of agree
with the GAO s assessment but that does
not mean that it's impeachable it just
means a problem between the executive
and the legislative branch that has a
statutory remedy you have Parnas stuff
the idea that the president was telling
him to go get people to shadow you mana
or that the president was telling
was telling Lev Parnas that he ought to
go dig up nefarious information on Joe
Biden or again that is third hand stuff
and the Democrats could have called
Parnas at any time and they could call
Giuliani at any time but they are not
calling any of these people which is at
the very least somewhat suspicious
better for them frankly that Trump gets
acquitted and then they can sit around
talking about how it's a giant cover-up
by all the Republicans I think that is
what they're looking for at this point
okay meanwhile in the 2020 Democratic
presidential race we saw Rock'em Sock'em
robots in the debate the other night it
was really between Sanders and Warren
Elizabeth Warren suddenly conveniently
remembered like two weeks out from the
Iowa caucuses which by the way are gonna
be wild because the Iowa caucuses this
year are gonna be held differently than
they have been in past years so
typically the Iowa caucus results comes
down to who has the most delegates
now the Democratic Party is going to
announce who has the most votes at the
beginning of the night who has the most
votes at the end of the night and the
number of Delegates
one which could create the ability for
several candidates to claim victory
because just because you win the most
votes does not mean that you win the
most delegates in caucus states because
again the caucuses are not held on raw
voting power not on aggregate voting
power right the way that you have
certain caucuses and the caucuses if a
majority of the caucus vote for a
candidate then all of that caucuses
electoral votes all of its delegates go
to that candidate so it's sort of like
the electoral college there could be a
difference between the popular vote in
the electoral college in Iowa
effectively speaking well that could
create room for conflict things getting
real wild well as they're saying
Elizabeth Warren the other night
suddenly conveniently remember two weeks
out that Bernie Sanders is a brutal
sexist and then you'll recall the
magical moment after to the debate where
Elizabeth Warren went up to Sanders
Sanders stuck out his hands and shake
her hand and she immediately started
berating him about something and Tom
Styer awkwardly in the background
started to back away like Homer Simpson
into the bushes
well now CNN has released the audio of
this exchange now I have a question how
is that even remotely journalistically
decent truly like that that's a serious
question now what we have all of these
like if you're on CNN and you're one of
the candidates your assumption fairly is
that after the debate is over your mic
is off right that is the assumption and
the fact that CNN is not like CNN is not
releasing the conversations that are
going on in the background right here
between Joe Biden and Tom Steyer or
anything right they're only releasing
the conversation between Warren and
Sanders I mean I think the Sanders
people have absolute reason to complain
here why is it that CNN is conveniently
releasing audio that is done off mic
effectively why and how do they have the
authority to do that and any
journalistic it's pretty impressive
anyway here is what actually got said
here's the problem for Warren it makes
her look even worse than she actually is
[Applause]
let's not do it right now you want to
have that discussion we'll have that you
call me you told me I'm starting I don't
want to get in the middle of this he
just sort of runs away okay Bernie comes
out better in that exchange cuz he's not
being a jerk hey Elizabeth Warren is
awful Elizabeth Warren is awful and she
comes off awfully in that exchange the
Sanders Warren thing is not good for the
Democratic Party it really is not which
is why party leaders are apparently
freaked out over the Warren Sanders
split the Washington Post has an entire
piece today about this freakout taking
place on the top level they say an angry
split among Liberal Democrats broke into
the open Wednesday has two prominent
presidential candidates exchanged
accusations of dishonesty raising fears
among party leaders of a repeat of the
internet' scene bitterness that many
Democrats say contributed to president
Trump's victory in 2016 the dispute
simmered all day between senators Bernie
Sanders and Elizabeth Warren over
whether he had told her that a woman
cannot win the presidency
social media users identifying
themselves as Sanders supporters used
snake icons to symbolize Warren's
extensible duplicity played up her
Republican roots and circulated a
hashtag at never worn hashtag Warren's
backers while taking a less aggressive
tone never nonetheless revived questions
of whether many of Sanders his
supporters are sexist and whether he
contributed to the party's disastrous
2016 loss with a display of
self-centered petulance so things are
getting ugly over in the Democratic
Party which is probably why they would
prefer to focus in on impeachment okay
time for a quick thing I like and then
we'll get to a thing I hate so things
that I like today well I guess it's time
to cancel the creators of James Bond I
think it's time to cancel the the
creators and owners of the rights in
James Bond so the rights in the in the
Bond franchise or held by Barbara
broccoli she oversees the franchise with
her half-brother Michael G Wilson that
was an arrangement first hammered out by
broccolis father the producer Albert
cubby broccoli when John F Kennedy was
president well now the broccoli family
is saying no we are not doing this whole
there's gonna be a female bond you know
why because it's idiotic okay so good
for them here's what broccoli says there
are certain things the duo of appears
open to considering this is occurring
variety and other conversations that are
non-starters when it comes to selecting
it the next Bond
it can be of any color but his mail says
broccoli I believe we should be creating
new characters for
strong female characters I'm not
particularly interested in taking a male
character and having a woman play it I
think women are far more interesting
than that okay it's time to cancel them
obviously they just said that women and
men are different and that you can't
just have a woman play a male character
or a male player play a female character
and then expected the dynamics are
exactly the same
this is unacceptable not in 2020 no not
as progressive as we have become every
female character should be played by a
male and every male character should be
played by a female because males and
females are exactly the same
we should remake Casablanca except that
Rick and Ilsa are Rick and Bob and we'll
make Claude Rains a girl just just I
don't know it let's just shake it all up
it's all the same it's all the same
because gender dynamics mean nothing now
I got a lot of flack from the left for
suggesting that I don't think that the
next James Bond it should be a female
and my suggestion was you have lots of
female action stars my wife and I last
night we started watching the new
Terminator movie it was out available
for rental it's actually pretty good I'm
kind of enjoying it hey Linda Hamilton
was a big action star back in the 1980s
you have lots of female action stars but
the key is that they're female and they
actually have female characteristics a
well-written part is a specific part
James Bond is a man if you change the
gender dynamics it does not work the
entire appeal of James Bond is that he
is a competent man who can bed any woman
that is that is the appeal of James Bond
as a character that is why he's a
long-standing character you know what we
call James Bond isn't rogue but he's a
rogue with a heart of gold because he's
and he is utterly capable with women so
he's wish fulfillment for a lot of dudes
you know what we call a a woman who can
bet any man we call her a woman because
it turns out that men and women are
completely different when it comes to
sexual relationships this is perfectly
obvious to anyone with a functioning
prefrontal cortex so good for the for
the broccoli family for saying no this
is a bunch of nonsense we're not doing
that the fact that the media we're
pushing it just demonstrates how out of
touch they are okay time for a quick
thing that I hate
with all the focus here in the United
States on domestic politics have you
noticed that America's two greatest
enemies are now lifelong dictatorships
so XI Jinping over in China has declared
himself dictator for life the Communist
Party is is ensconced well ensconced
there presumably for as long as the West
allows it to be without any sort of
economic sanctions that is a dangerous
move especially because China is getting
more and more aggressive on the
international stage as the people of
Hong Kong can attest well yesterday we
found out that Vladimir Putin has
essentially made himself dictator for
life
this has been true since he took office
in what 1999 he's been in power for
twenty years at this point he will die
in office
according to Russia today Prime Russian
Prime Minister Dmitry Medvedev has
announced that the entire government is
resigning in a surprise statement
released shortly after President
Vladimir Putin delivered his annual
State of the Nation Address accepting
the resignation Putin thanked the
ministers for their hard work and asked
them to function as a caretaker
government until a new one can be formed
Medvedev and Putin had met for a work
meeting to discuss the State of the
Nation Address earlier on Wednesday met
avid Medvedev explained that the cabinet
is resigning in accordance with article
117 of the Russian Constitution which
states but the government can offer its
resignation to the president who can
either accept or reject it during his
speech Putin said he intended to create
the position of Deputy Secretary of
Russia's Security Council which would
then be offered to Medvedev so instead
of Medvedev having a sort of an
independent position in the Russian
government now he will just be purely
and simply without any sort of without
any sort of obfuscation a a lackey of
Putin directly
Medvedev's moves in the new rule will
mean Russia will have a new prime
minister when a new government is formed
basically Putin runs the place he runs
the place like a thug that he is a
dictator he is one of the world's worst
people this is why when he heard people
on the right these days defending
Vladimir Putin why can't we be friends
with what because he is an old KGB thug
who wishes to maximize Russia's security
presence in the world expand its borders
and oppress dissenters he's a bad man
and he just enshrined his own
dictatorship basically forever Putin
also proposed multiple amendments to
Russia's Constitution his proposals
would entail substantial changes to the
Constitution as well as to the entire
balance of power the power of the
executive the power of the legislature
the power of the judiciary so Putin will
now
now under the Putin plan the State Duma
which is the lower house of parliament
will be granted the power to appoint the
Prime Minister and the rest of the
cabinet as opposed to just approving
their candidacies as is currently the
case and the State Duma is basically run
by Putin another idea voiced by Putin is
to make the consultation body the State
Council a permanent fixture with its
status and role written into the
Constitution the president praised the
council's effectiveness stressing its
working groups ensure that the most
global product the most important
problems for the people are thoroughly
looked into even according to RT which
is a russian government outlet basically
they say that this is they say that this
is a step towards diversification of
power yes sure sure it is that is such
obvious nonsense ok the Putin made
himself dictator for life yesterday it's
it's it weakens anybody who would take
over but it's a shake up that that keeps
them in power long or effectively
speaking so that is effectively what
happened in Russia don't worry guys he's
our ally already we'll be back here
later today with all the latest
developments and news is breaking fast
you're gonna want to stick around for
that otherwise we'll see you here
tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca dab poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Sterling technical producer austin
stevens associate producer colton haas
assistant director pablo i douse key
edited by adam sai events audio is mixed
by micro mina hair and makeup is by jl
alvera production assistant nick Sheehan
the Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]